hello there you may be expecting a map
update video from me today but this new
island is so huge it would take a week
to break down so instead i've compiled
24 map secrets i think you should see
for yourself this includes easter eggs
jokes hints to the future and the past
of fortnite and a boatload of nostalgia
for chapter one players so if you do me
the honour of rocking code adamaru this
chapter let's do this
[Music]
where the freak do we start on an island
this big with the biggest easter egg of
all of course over on the far left
hiding under the water in a shallow cove
is this chapter one ogs recognize it
right away this is the lost arm from the
day the devourer and the largest mech in
history had a dust up over the zero
point singularity's mech had its arm
ripped off that day and it was thrown in
this exact location back in july 2019.
this is one of about 50 ways the chapter
3 map aligns with the original island
but that's a conversation for another
video i also checked underneath the
ground to make doubly sure the arm
wasn't connected to anything it isn't
yet over to the daily bugle and
spider-man's day job in here are so many
desks it's tough to know which one is
important so i'll help you out at the
foot of these stairs is a desk covered
in marvel references from venom to
wolverine hang on though because some of
these are not in fortnite yet so these
are likely hints to the future we have
the x-men both cyclops and jubilee in
yellow and blue spandex and to the right
of this is a newspaper headline about
the green goblin one of spider-man's
most revered enemies hello my dear this
must be foreshadowing and at a push is
this a photo of miles morales i mean
it's a black suit it's got red graffiti
text and there's a new movie coming out
soon all we need now is spider gwen
when chapter three started i ran to find
gnomes you know after they all
disappeared at the end of the last
chapter i was unable to find them yet
there is one reference to the gnomes
here up at the tippity top of the island
is a mansion with a maze behind it here
we can spot nods to the old coliseum but
get to the center of it and you'll find
this the cyborg gnome memorial this is a
nod to season 4 of chapter 2 when a mad
scientist came to the island in an
attempt to eradicate all the gnomes
there he met his demise when we chased
him down to the swamps and he crash
landed while escaping
so press x to pay your respects this led
me to try and find the mortal enemy of
genomes everywhere the misfit bears the
last time we saw them they had just
signed a treaty of peace yep that's a
real thing in fortnite right now a bunch
of those bears have made it to camp
cuddle a few of them can be seen at the
kitchen table and another one is
watching tv still wearing his helmet of
war i wonder what shenanigans these guys
will get up to over the next two years
whilst here look outside and you'll see
three chalets side by side one for each
different type of cuddle team leader the
middle one is full of ducks it's insane
no it's quackers
thank you very much to the right of that
is a treasure trove of deadpool
references before entering look at the
ground and you'll see wade's original
sketch for a brand new battle bus which
became a thing in season two chapter two
inside is deadpool's favorite floating
device and also you'll find his socks at
the base of a toilet which legend has it
he takes off when pooping the more you
know in the next cubicle is another
floating device and pop quiz who was the
last character to own this thing time's
up it was batman back when batman made
the bat shed before escaping the loop
he'll be back to collect this it's his
favorite unicorn speaking of the season
deadpool was introduced the same battle
pass gave us other characters who have
little references in the game right now
brutus's punch bag can be found on your
travels and should you visit this spot
at the volcano you'll find weapons and
tech first seen in tiantina's room and
midas room over at the old rig you know
before it went boom this leads on to
another huge easter egg which may have
story implications just above the rock's
rock statue there is a modern building
seemingly a restaurant of some sort yet
things are not as they seem here take a
look at the reservation book and it's
actually midas sketchbook from designing
the device what a good event that was
there is also an ego logo reference here
and look around and you'll discover the
napkins all have a capital m upon them
could this be foreshadowing midas return
or is this just a small easter egg for
those who should get out more another
great spot you should visit is just a
little bit further north at this seven
compound where agent jones chills out if
like me you're a fan of the story and
the law but you get a little forgetful
or missed something be sure to come here
regularly to listen to the recordings
and replay the logs it's crazy useful if
a little buggy right now
[Music]
let's jump back a few days to the end
event there's a bunch of easter eggs and
jokes worth mentioning here first did
you see the size of agent jones's brain
it's scanned in the background and this
guy's brain box is tiny but he has a big
heart as we are escaping and following
the scientists he promises us a water
break it's right up here and i will give
you a water break field which ended up
being extremely true as the caretaker
cracked the window into the sea and we
ultimately spent a day or two floating
on the waters so thanks for that water
break scientist did you know that whilst
we were waiting for the new chapter to
begin the cut scene never stopped moving
forwards it just happened unbelievably
slowly but if we speed it all up this is
the full animation leading all the way
up to washing up on the beach whilst
floating and waiting it was possible to
see different types of debris floating
past like the derburger head or a loot
box
those who are extra lucky could also see
spider-man's backpack in the water or
even the sacred zapatron washed out to
sea from the i o facility in fact many
of the items from the among us mode have
made it onto the new island with my
favorite being the peely punching bag
taken straight from jones's i o room he
also had a deactivated kevin the cube we
last saw rolling around in the science
wing i'll keep an eye on this each week
and i'll let you know if it changes
color and reactivates one day all of
these are small subtle little nods and
easter eggs for losers like me and you
to find so happy days but wait there are
more and we'll do these extra quick as
youtube tells me this is the time most
people start clicking off and also 69 of
you aren't subscribed yet so click the
thing if you wouldn't mind thanks mostly
anyway back to easter eggs over in the
northwest of the island by the shoreline
is a famous ditty you can hear the sound
of the wobbly blubs at present only one
of the crustaceans has made it here
maybe more are coming in the meantime
you should totally go visit him for
extra luck oh wait whilst we're here
look at this one of the connectors from
the battle bus currently sits dormant on
a hillside but it's only here in replay
files as i haven't finished my
challenges this week i don't know if
this is relevant or not but i thought
i'd mention it there's also two others
around here too as it's christmas
crackshot's cabin has returned for the
month it's the exact same as it was back
in chapter one the christmas tree the
lights the weird picture above the fire
it's not christmas until you've visited
this place and remember it usually
vanishes in january remember when drift
brought random items from our reality to
the island like the easter island heads
well those things have returned again
this chapter with this one being my
favorite i call him derek there is a
really mysterious mound here on the map
with hot air venting out of it stand
here long enough and you'll hear some
strange sounds like those we heard when
the polar peak monster was stuck in the
rock face i guess if the mex army's here
the monster could be here too i think a
round two is deserved likely though this
is where one of those tractor-like
dinosaurs will be sleeping until they
become a thing later in the season and
if not there is another reason for it
being here this hot air is actually
melting around them right now including
the poi which is unnamed
thanks to leakers and those people who
have lots of time on their hands it is
now almost 100 confirmed that this is
tilted towers locked in ice the place
that everyone thinks they want back but
actually is the place where most people
go to die happy memories give it six
weeks and we should have back tilted
towers if you've kept an eye on fortnite
videos you'll know that there's a gears
of war crossover coming to the game and
right now it's possible to find the
cinder block barricades all around the
island with a gears logo upon them
graffitied onto the site can i quickly
note how much i appreciate logos with
cogs and gears in them gg on that design
and finally in the battle pass on
spider-man's page is the it's you emote
this is the highly mean spider-man
imposter image you've seen so many times
before you can now recreate it whenever
you like so if someone's rocking your
skin and you don't like it you have this
emote memes in fortnite who'da thunk it
we did it 24 map secrets jokes and
easter eggs all in chapter three's first
day in existence thanks for sticking
around to the end and thanks if you've
used code adamaru i'll be back in my
twitter dms to thank you all personally
because you doing that lets me call this
a job so thank you very much okay i love
you bye
[Music]